Aaaaah (très viril.) j'ai besoins d'ma dose de Battle Royal finir le dernier joueur en vie alors
qu'il y en a 100 ! *Orgasme extrême*
Woaaah ! Qu'est-ce-que c'est que ça?
Des niveaux ?!  Une boutique ? Des skins ?
Allez... Des achats in-game à tout va, comme d'hab...
Vous m'aurez pas avec ça les mecs...
[bruit de pigeon qui s'envole]
[musique du pigeon qui achète des trucs]
Okay! *Satisfait* Maintenant, on peut y aller! Comment-allez vous?  Moi ça va très bien
J'suis très content d'être de retour sur Fortnite je m'étais beaucoup amusé quand on avait fait la première vidéo
*Moment : Modéstie* : En plus j'vais pas vous mentir on avait fait un TOP 1, et ça mec c'est
un des plus beaux souvenirs de ma carrière YouTube c'est fou *voix fébrile ^^*
Mais aujourd'hui on va refaire
la même chose et en plus avec style parce qu'on a des skins trop beaux
Qui coûte 20 balles #Pigeon *Rires* C'est parti
Olalalala ça fait longtemps
J'suis excité comme une petite puce! (Non sexuellement parlant calme toi.) On va aller
A Salty Springs, c'est nouveaux ?! J'avais jamais vu ça Salty Springs
Allons faire une petite visite par là-bas et voyons qui s'y cache! Alright alright
*pulsion* Oh l'batard il est devant fait chier! Il a un parapluie ça veut dire qu'il a déjà fait TOP 1 *Moment modéstie #2* Ah mais moii aussi en faite, et en vidéo.
[musique JEAN SANFLAMME]
J'vais l'dire toutes les minutes que j'ai fait TOP 1
Ok lui j'me l'fait j'm'en bats les couilles
Ok heu je change d'avis #Tapette je pars
Fils de pute, fils de pute nique ta race (Non ce n'est pas les sous titres automatique que vous lisez ^^)
J'ai 1 HP !! Tu m'auras pas'euh ! Nananananère (C'est pas les sous titres automatique j'ai dit ^^)
[bruit de pas très proches]
*Pan pan! Suivi d'un rire très viril comme d'hab*
J'm'en fous j't'ais fais perdre du temps pendant que tu me chassais tous les autres ont looté et tu vas mourir #Sadique
Aaaaah ! Quelle bonne première game (Même nul il est modeste, abusé) *Rire*
* Parle anglais y'a déjà les sous titre de Squeezie j'vous laisse lires.*
*Swiiip* OOOH ! Je lui ai pris les munitions
Il a l'arme mais j'ai les munitiooooooooonsss ! *:D*
c dur la vi :////
Ok les amis la strat(égie) ça va être d'aller a Pleasant Park !
On va se lâcher au niveau du lac juste ici c'est une excellente strat(égie) :D
Là on va looter mon pote allez hop fusil à pompes m'en bats les couilles mon pote! Grenade allez hop! suivant. #Insolent
OUI UN SNIPERRRR, mais mec! On est d'accord y'a personne'n'hein, j'ai pas vu 1 putain d'rat
Allez on s'casse bon bah on est bien regardez résultats des courses on a un fusil à pompes
Un sniper, une "AR" et un p'tit heal kit !
*muisique badass ;)*
C'EST COMME CA QU'ON FAIT!! PUTAAAIIN... !
Owh il m'a fait owh j'vous jures il m'a énervé! là j'pense qu'on va faire TOP 1 #GrosseTête, il m'a énervé.
*Rire de merde* Donc là à tout moment une balle de snipe(r) me tue hein, c'est ça qu'il faut
se dire je n'ai pas d'potions je suis mal mal mal mal
Ah ! ça se tire dessus là bas..
*Glupp c'est raté dmg ;)* MERDE.. ! Il a bougé au moment ou'n'a tiré Tabarnacle ! (Tabarnak pour les intimes ^^)
Oh! Attention à ma droite ! Putain qu'est-ce-que j'suis pas serein, on est plus que 18!
Va-t-il faire TOP 1?!
Attends.
*Try-hard* Y'a un mec. *Le retour d'la musique Badass ;)*
Voilà allez ça dégage, ça c'est qu'on appelle l'ouïe, l'ouïe du rat hein!
Même si un rat sa entend pas forcément bien c'est pas grave! J'vais me barrer par là pendant qu'ils font leurs
petits bails. *Fait de la merde avec le bois...*
Ok ça c'est des constructions qu'on appelle vraiment
Vraiment utiles.
TOUINNN ! *Musique badass enchaînée.*
NOOOOON ! Mais j'ai été si nul?! O_O Mais c'est fou! Owh regarde ça me démange.. O_o
Naaan mec... C'est scandaleux..! J'ai HONTE.
Revenons sur ce qu'il c'est passé (T nul cherche pas ^^) : Quand Squeezie a vu l'adversaire
sa pression artérielle a augmentée ce qui a provoqué un échec de visé
Assez conséquent.
La suite très rapidement
*Se mouche* C'est pas grave on va y arriver! :'(
Y'a personne dans les airs tout l'monde est derrière moi
Ca c'est très bon ça ! YEEES !
*Musique posée ptn c cool la vi oft :o*
Et voilà on en parle plus, Mank0o a manqué(e) à l'appel, merci.
Olalalala vous avez eu l'temps d'le voir ou pas? C'est allé tellement vite
Que même moi j'me suis dit "Putain mais y'avait vraiment un mec" *Rire sataniqué, démoniaque* Mwaha! J'ais bien trop l'mec.
Ok on va se cacher sous l'arbre là bas à l'afro et on va camper
T'sais quoi on va l'couper en fait on a besoin d'bois
Oh putain.
Comment j'fais pour être aussi nul la question est légitime :///
"Aaaah'" *Chant d'Eglise* WAOW ! Oh yes!
Mais putain mais c'est dingue moi j'pense y'a justice dans c'monde.
Il arrive.
CA VIENT DU CIEL LE DANGER, MON POTE ! :D
Une puissance divine veille sur nous, c'est sûr. Alooors, on c'est fait un p'tit fief et on va veiller. OWWHH on a la zone regardez , on est presque dedans :) deja
On a trop d'chance ça a spawn de notre côté! Y'a une divinité. J'vous jure y'a un dieu qui s'est mis de notre côté (modestie x9000)
Je sais pas qui, Apollon, Atena, je sais pas :S Mais y'a quelqu'un qui est avec nous aujourd'hui!
MANIFESTES-TOI! *Explosion passion du montage* Oh putain c'est Zeus!
Ce qui fait lui là bas? Putin mais c'est dingue je le regarde construire mes il fait ça si bien. J'ai envie de tout péter juste pour tout voir tomber ça serait magnifique.
Ça a pas marché
Il n’est pas mort mais c’est juste pour le plaisir!
J’aime pas quand ça file dans la forêt
A tout moment derrière un arbre y’a toujours un mec qui nous attend. Je suis sérieux.
Putain de ta mère
*musique BADASS encore*
Oh la la il nous a même pas touché
Qu’il est mauvais. Il nous a donné des fournitures. 'Tain je dis fourniture je suis un bébé!
Ah, j’ai entendu du lance grenade, j’ai entendu du lance grenade, je suis en panique!
Je le vois on est 5
Yes! On va faire top 1 si rapidement dans cette vidéo!
Mon cœur bat la chamarade. C’est pas expression, j'm’en fout!
Plus que 4 c’est pas possible
*musique stressante*
Hop là tu est mort. Aller suivant! On est 3, mais les 2 ils peuvent être ou?
Mais c'est dingue ça !
Comment on peut être 3 je ne comprends pas expliquez moi!
Ou alors ils on fait une alliance les mecs?
Nan :c
J’ai envie de lancer une gre... pour la barre. Allez vas-y. Pour la barre, juste pour faire peur
Hé je suis puissant ok!
Ok vas-y venez j'vous attend. C'est maintenant qu'on va les cueillir.
Ok lui je le vois!
Plus de shield... Il est mort! Ok le dernier! Il est derrière l’arbre qui est là
Bon aujourd’hui c’était pas...si difficile!
YES!
Mais attend la video va être trop courte!
J'etais aussi rapide qu’un... ok j’arrête les métaphores!
J’en ai marre de faire des comparaisons de merde!
C’est fou, mais vraiment! Zeus, tout ça ces grâce a toi. Viens faire une apparition.
Ou bien manifeste toi!
Les amis écoutez comme Zeus est avec nous aujourd'hui j'propose qu'on mette la barre plus haute et qu'on fasse
deux TOP 1 dans la même vidéo (OMG ça tourne mal.)
Let's do it.
*Se prend une balle*
Une très bonne game. Putaaain Zeus nous a quitté là..!
C'est *souffle* *phhh..* C'est dur là.. :(. Bon j'vais pas vous mytho parfois j'me dope
Pour être bon aux jeux vidéo, c'est-à-dire une fois par année hein.. Vu mon niveau tout l'reste de l'année
Faut juste que j'insuffle un peu de puissance dans cet appareil. #PrayForSkouizi
*Enorme rot bien degueulasse* (La légende raconte qu'un tremblement de terre aurait touché la France)
Alright, alright! nous allons atterrir sur ce merveilleux terrain de basket ! C'est faux.
Y'a jamais de loot, c'est une idée de merde. C'est de la merde. Même si vous aimez le basket ne faîtes jamais ça.
On va plutôt aller dans ces maisons là v'là généralement y'a des choses incroyables, dans celle ci
Surtout celle-ci. Voiiilà le pire (fusil à) pompe du jeu, on l'a !
Il est en notre possession! (soi pa fier)
Pardon (x3) c'était une blague
Et BOOOM! C'était pas une blague mon pote *Rire*
En faite la blague c'est que je t'ai dit que c'était une blague mais c'était pas une blague *Accent belge #jcvd*
A bientôt ! Putain là on est vénère j't'dis ! Là j'ai un insufflé
une "pouffé'" une pouffé?! O_O J'ai insufflé une bouffé de puissance!
TIENS! LA POUFFE DE PUISSANCE ELLE EST LA ! LA BOUFFE DE PUISSANCE PUTAIN J'EN ai marre de bugué sur ce mot !
NAAAAN !! AAANWHHH... Naan..Il avait du bouclier..
Ohw mais j'en ai pas pris assez c'est vrai que d'habitude c'est un peu plus *SNIFFFF*
Personne ne m'emmerdera plus jamais!! :@
visage de la terreur très clairement <<<<<<<<<<<
*Cri incompréhensible*
*Perd son énergie* Owh, qu'est-ce-qu'il m'arrive ?! Nan..NAAAAAAAAAAN !
Et ben les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur Fortnite n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plus.
Hélas j'ai pas la puissance de Broly, j'ai plutôt la puissance de Bulma.
C'qui n'est pas la même chose.. N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plus.. Putain
J'me suis éclaté, j'aime trop les Battle Royal (#Geek) ça m'avait manqué!
J'sais pas pourquoi j'avais complétement arrêté pendant 1 mois' là. Mais mec j'vais retomber addict c'est terrible!
*Rire :'D Lol c drol h1.
On a quand même fait un petit TOP 1 ! C'est la règle on finit pas une vidéo sans faire TOP 1
J'ai rempli ma part du marché j'espère que ça vous a plu ! J'vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Portez vous bieen. J'pars comme un Saiyan.
orv tlm.
Merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo, merci à l'équipe pour avoir fait les sous titres, ABONNE-TOI ! :)
Peace.